[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
aka cobb vance vance refrigeration and
this video we're breaking down
everything you need to know about the
character before he first appeared in
the mandalorian
cobb had a long and rich history that
makes him
a big fan favorite in star wars expanded
lore
cobb first debuted in aftermath which
told his origin story and how he rose to
become a sheriff
known as the marshall now cobb's origin
story
is sort of in line with what we see play
out in the show however
as mando hadn't been invented at the
time of his creation
his arc does differ slightly cobb
similar to anakin was a slave
and after he was freed from this he
stumbled across the town of mospelgo
pelgo had been raided by a syndicate
known as the red key raiders
and they had pretty much ransacked the
area
in the source material when traversing
the location
van came across a red key raider known
as edwin chiru
who was at a sand crawler banthe agreed
to help churu scavenge valuable
equipment from the vehicle
and this is where the pair found boba
fett's armor it turns out that boba fett
had escaped the sarlacc
and he was found by jowas who then
stripped him of the equipment
but that's a topic for another video if
you do want to know the ins and outs of
it though yeah
then make sure you check out our video
on how boba fett survived which will be
linked at the
end otherwise i'll bloody fight you now
both chiru and vanth
wanted the armor and the latter managed
to best the former
taking it for himself cobb allowed chiru
to live
so that he could pass on a warning to
his boss logan mavelin
in the hopes that he would leave the
town he didn't
and not long after vanth returned to mos
palgo
and single-handedly drove away the
raiders he became the sheriff of the
area
and this is pretty similar to what we
see happen in the show
now most palgo was actually renamed to
freetown
and cobb trained up the residents of the
area so that they would be ready to
fight off any more raider attacks
these came several times and the village
was raided at multiple points
but the locals managed to fight back the
death of jabba the hutt had really
caused the power struggle on the planet
and without the empire there to occupy
things either
there were several other factions that
rose in the vacuum that was created
now the books themselves namely the
aftermath collection
follows cobb as he goes through the
trials and tribulations of being a
sheriff
one centers around cobb stopping the red
key raiders from smuggling out a hutlet
and he even kills malakili who who you
will know from return of the jedi and
i'm sorry so sad and not long after this
the raiders launched an attack on mos
palgo which was led by
none other than logan turns out that
mavalan wanted to enslave the people of
pelgo
and the villain was actually planning on
taking over the entirety of tatooine
in the wake of the power vacuum however
cobb was ready for him
and palgo had formed a unity with the
tuscan raiders in the area
in order to fight off mavellen's forces
cobin co defeated logan
and palgo was safe once more now
depending on what stories you read
depends on a lot of things that could
happen with the character
in some of the expanded lore boba fett
does get his armor back at some point
but how he does this depends purely on
what you pick up
there are a lot of avenues in which this
could happen and it is quite interesting
that in the show
fett didn't actually go after vanth
himself we do know that the armor is
pretty much
laser proof and maybe ferret was biting
his time until cobb dropped his guard
or it was removed from him fett has
tuscan raider garbon
and it is possible that he was living
amongst them in the desert
waiting for the perfect moment to take
it back he and mando will likely find
some common ground
and it is possible that because he is a
clone that he will help define the
origins of baby oda
who if the theory turns out to be true
is a clone of yoda
now the expanded universe dealt with a
lot of stories in which baba continued
his journey as a bounty hunter
and he even had a family at some point
we're kind of getting a bit sidetracked
here but as for vanth
i think that this season will likely
follow a similar sort of path to the
original one
in which mando slowly started to build
up allies
remember that moth gideon is still after
him and van would prove to be a powerful
ally
even if he no longer has his mandalorian
armor i doubt that this is the last that
we will see of the character
and i think it would be amazing if we
got him back at some point
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the character so make sure
you comment below and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then drop a
thumbs up yeah and make sure you check
out our breakdown of who the mysterious
character at the end of the latest
episode of the mandalorian could be
don't forget we're giving away three
copies of the marvel phase two box set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below the winner is going to be chosen
at random on the 30th of november
so make sure you get involved our
winners of last month's competition are
now on our community tab
so definitely check that out after this
you want to support the channel
and get to see content early and please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also become chapters on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul i'll
see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
um